Recall we discussed that public key
encryption is typically used to
establish a symmetric key for encrypting
messages for say between Alice and Bob.
That is, before Alice and
Bob can communicate securely
they would use public key's encryption
to exchange a sure and secret key.
Of course, Alice and
Bob can first establish this key
before Alice can send Bob the first
message encrypted using this key.
But with Public Key Encryption we can
do better, meaning that we can do
it in a more efficient way with so
called digital envelopes.
Alice can send Bob a message encrypted
using a share key that she just created,
and this share secret key itself is
encrypted using Bob's public key, so
that only Bob can decrypt and
extract the share secret key.
This is similar to the situation where
only the intended recipient
can open the sealed envelope.
To illustrate,
Alice first creates a symmetric key
that she wants to share with Bob.
She can encrypt a message
using this share key,
then she also uses Bob's public
key to encrypt this share key.
And then she can put
the encrypted message and
the encrypted key in envelope.
Then she can put the encrypted message
and the encrypted key together and
send them to Bob.
On the receiving end,
Bob can use his private key to
decrypt the encrypted share key.
Once he gets a shared key, he can now
decrypt the encrypted message and
get a plain text message.